all right
Lana Lana where you from originally
where'd you grow up Los Angeles
California what part South Central
Compton Compton yes tell me about your
family growing up my family um
originally from California um I'm not
sure where my mother's side and Family's
from but um come from a large
family um my mother was the youngest out
of four boys I believe
and um her mother died when she was 12
so she basically was on her own since
she was 12 and um
she she had me by the time she was uh 15
she had a my oldest sister at
14 and at I think 17 she had my first
brother by the time she was 21 she had
my last brother and stuff so by the time
she was 22 she had four kids and a
single mother um she was also on um
barbituates at the
time um me I was told that I was born
with a barbit in my system so they had
taken me from my mom they didn't think I
was going to live cuz I had seizures and
stuff and I mean my life is kind of
tragic from the
beginning I can
remember me being in McClaren Hall I
think I was about 4 years old at the
time because I had been raped by um one
of my mother's friends and they took her
took me from her and I remember being in
this cage it was like a being in a jail
cell and I remember me just crying for
my mom not understanding why I was taken
away from her and um I never been around
excuse me a lot of white people at the
time and that's all I seen you know so I
just cried I remember me just crying
because these faces was not familiar to
me at all and nobody could explain to me
you know what was going on I end up
eventually going back with my
mother and
um unfortunately I was dragged through
the you know the drug houses and uh the
different things that she went through
she took me everywhere with her but she
would leave my other siblings at home by
themselves um I think she was afraid
that you know they would take me from
her
again at um let me
see as 6 years old my mother um
committed suicide she was
22 and I was left in there laying on her
body for hours I mean it was daytime but
by the time someone came it was uh it
was night time and I remember them
working on her and telling me they was
going to take her to the hospital she
was going to be okay but nobody never
told told me that she died all I know is
that I was bounced around from foster
home to foster homes and that was the
last time I seen my brothers me and my
sister was putting foster homes together
and today I wouldn't even know what my
brother look like and hopefully I hope
he's watching this and see this
um my sister since passed away um she
had a lot of animosity towards me
because my mother like I said kept me
with her and kept my sister in that
house you know I remember no lights I
remember the house being dirty you know
um by my mother being on drugs I
remember me taking care of her when she
would OD I knew what to do for her and
stuff I became the
caretaker you know um her getting
physical confrontation with me and I
remember me fighting with her you
know um I say about um at 6 years old my
um mother's brother and his wife adopted
me and my
sister um I still didn't know what
happened to my mom still no one would
tell
me but um I thought it would be a
good life to live with them I didn't
know I was going to be living them you
know for the rest of my
life the material things we had you know
the houses and everything was okay but
behind that it was abuse I was
um beat with horse whoops water hoses
sticks um at a very young age my first
whipping my uncle literally knocked me
out by stepping on my chest that was the
beginning the first and the beginning of
a a long period of abuse physical
abuse excuse me take your time
during that time um like I
said the material things we
had but behind that it was a lot of
abuse
and then I started being not only being
a beat because I couldn't say my
alphabets right or I couldn't ride a
bike the way I was taught
to
um I was hit all the time that's how I
was taught if I was told once or twice
this is a a or this is a b and I didn't
get it right I would get slapped or
knock you know um that's how I was
talk so I
became um withdrawn you know um I
started inflicting pain on myself
um during that time I constantly asked
about my
mom but no one ever said anything
um my cousins what always always tell me
that's not your mom that's my mom you
know and and just do little things to uh
you know hurt me at the time my sister
was there and I used to tell her come on
let's go I used to want to tell my older
sister let's go let's run away and go
find our mom but my sister said no she
we need to stay I started running away
at s years old sleeping in
Parts
um because of the beatings and nobody
beli me you know they would always take
me back and I would get beat again for
you know saying anything from there they
started putting me in um psychiatric
hospitals um my first psychiatric
hospital I think I was uh 9 years
old I didn't know why I was in there all
I know if they took me there and I they
start to give me shots
of medicine or whatever um I didn't
understand why I was
there
um I used to tell my aunt when come and
see me that I I wanted to get out of
there because I didn't like what was
happening to
me but I end up stand and at the period
of time I would go back to my aunt and
uncle
home nobody would help me no
teacher the law enforcement because they
looked at the
outside you know my uncle was a school
teacher he was well known
my aunt you know she was a caterer she
was well known and um nobody would help
me I I became that person that was lying
making up
stories and I just don't understand how
a child that young can make up you know
stories like
that as I got
older I was put in girls homes there was
a lot of prejudice in there because um
majority of people that was in there was
Hispanics were whites and maybe one or
two blacks in there so um that's when I
first started experiencing
racism
um and I remember me being called [__]
and stuff and me lashing out and I would
be the one to get punished and I can
understand why you
know we didn't have uh I didn't have
nobody to talk
to
you know even in there I when I last
start or whatever because of the me
being caught [__] they would put me in
this room it was called an isolation
room and it had just a bed in the
punching bag and I remember being in
there for days and days and days and
when I would get out these girls homes I
had so much anger um I can I just got
worse you know I would run away every
every chance I could get I would run
away and um I eventually get emancipated
at 15 I think not knowing how to read
not having no kind of financial support
went to Children's court and they said
you on your own and that was it just
downtown Los Angeles not knowing what
was going to happen to me I end up
meeting a um this lady and she took me
in and if it wasn't for her I would have
never made it to Job Corp I end up going
to job core getting my GED and getting
my nursing
certificate um that was the first thing
I accomplished that I feel good about
you know in my life cuz up until then I
hadn't done anything I didn't know how I
was scared
too um I didn't want to try because if I
tried and didn't get it right you know I
would U get
beat and that's where I started
um doing um trying to find out who I was
uh as a
person and I had a
I had a lot of good opportunities in job
core but my um history you know the
abuse and stuff it would just um come
back and I would like self self-sabotage
myself um not really I when I had good
things good things started happening in
my life I was sabotaging because I was
so used to the bad things to the good
things didn't feel normal so I see now
that I caused a lot of um problems on
myself as I got older in my 20s and
stuff at um 21 I had my first
child yeah I thought dang I had a baby
now I can love her like I wanted to be
loved and all though I meant that I was
not able to because of my mental state I
started using drugs at uh 26 years
old and I feel into that heart because
it was something that made me feel
different than other what I was feeling
you know I didn't I didn't um that pain
I didn't feel no more I didn't it made
me not care and um I struggle with
that I end up getting uh you know
married uh not
even in love with the person I married I
did it for family sake trying to uh get
them to uh love me and accept
me but eventually I end up leaving cuz
again my mental state again I had to go
back out and medicate
myself cuz that's the only way I could
deal with
me
you
today my struggle is not as
hard all the people in my past that
reached out to help me than I didn't
accept I go back and I try to apply them
things to my life today it is not easy
but it's better than it was
yesterday you
know
you have kids now yes my kids are grown
and have their own kids now um our
relationships are not good at all I'm
hoping that if they do see this there's
some way they can see in their
heart what what happened to me and how
come I wasn't able to be the mother that
I wanted to be to them and that they
deserve to have in their
life because I know the problems that I
had impact on their decisions and they
life you know um and I hope that it stop
you know somewhere it you know that pain
is STO going from generation to
generation how old are you now I'll be
59 Sunday happy birthday thank you I
never thought I would make
it what was the darkest point of your
life the darkest point of my life is
where I got two the day I laid on my
mother's body
all them hours and my kids me giving um
parental rights to my um and an uncle
because I couldn't uh take care of my
kids and the drug was crack yes how long
did that last um I've been struggling
with it all the way up until still
you're still yes still today off and on
not so much but still it's still in my
life you
know um how have you made money over the
years um when I had first started this I
did all kind of things I stole I had
even prostituting for a short time you
know um I couldn't do that because
uh that molestation thing I been I
probably been in
jail killing people I couldn't deal with
that but I end up um started cleaning up
houses and stuff
um and because I did such a good job I
started getting other people and that's
how I've been doing it working with my
family business is catering and stuff
you
know um I don't do the things on the
streets like I used to anymore I try
to uh clean up houses or whatever even
if I have to recycle you know whatever
but I don't turn to the the prostitution
and stealing and stuff that's that's
been on my life for years but it was
part of my life you know do you have
anything you look forward to or hope for
in your life
yes I I would like for me and my
kids well for me to know that my kids
love me and accept
me before I leave this
earth the wonder what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your
life to never give
up no matter how dark it seems don't
give
up all right L thank you so much for
sharing your story thank
you